but in this video we're going to talk
about where it just keeps on going and
going and going right so you want to
find the sum of all those terms and it's
geometric you're multiplying by the same
ratio to get to the next term and so the
form that we're gonna be using is this
one over here the sum of an infinite
geometric series equals a sub 1 over 1
minus R now this doesn't work for finite
it's only for infinite and you have to
make sure that the ratio the absolute
value of the ratio is less than 1 or you
can also state it as the ratio has to be
in between negative 1 and positive 1
otherwise if the ratio was 2 like say
for example it was 4 then 8 and 16 and
32 and 64 you can see it's just going to
keep getting a large or large or larger
that's what we call a divergent okay
series mean it's going to infinity or to
negative infinity what we want to do is
we want it to be convergent say for
example you're multiplying by 1/3 like
you know 90 times 1/3 is 30 and then 30
times the third is 10 and then 10 thirds
and 10 ninths and it's getting smaller
and smaller approaching 0 you can sum up
all those terms and find out what that
sum is as the number of terms approaches
infinity right so what we're going to do
in this one is we're look at a couple
examples we're gonna start off with a
hundred and then the next term is 50 25
12.5 so what are we multiplying by to
get to the next term in this series well
50 divided by 100 is 1/2 25 divided by
50 is 1/2 so you just take the term
divided by the one before it to find the
ratio and so we're gonna use this
formula the first term is 100 okay 1
minus the ratio which we said was 1/2
and it meets our requirements that it's
less than 1 okay it's in between
negative 1 and positive 1 so it's gonna
converge you can see this is getting
smaller and smaller it's approaching
zero so what we get for our sum our
infinite sum is 100 divided by 1/2 okay
when you divide by fresh and it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal so the sum
of all these terms they're gonna add up
to 200 you can kind of see that this is
150 then 175 180 7.5 and it's just
slower slower slower it's gradually
approaching the 200 mark
okay let's look at another example let's
look at this one here here we've got
twenty seven eighths plus 9/4 plus
three-halves what do we multiply an by
to get to the next term here this is a
little bit more challenging because of
the fractions but again what you can do
is you can take any term and divide it
by the previous term so nine fourths
divided by twenty seven eighths when you
divide by a fraction it's like
multiplying by the reciprocal okay so I
just flip that over we're going to do
some reducing okay it looks like it's
two thirds let's check another term
three-halves divided by five nine four
three halves divided by nine force when
you divide it's like multiplying by the
reciprocal okay so this we can reduce
this we can reduce it looks like we're
getting 2/3 again and two-thirds meets
our requirement of being in between
negative one and one that means that
this is going to be getting smaller
smaller smaller it's going to be
approaching zero and we can add up all
the terms so let's go ahead and use our
formula the sum of an infinite geometric
series it's the first term which is
twenty seven eighths divided by one
minus the ratio which we found out was
two-thirds do a little bit of arithmetic
here we've got twenty seven eighths
divided by one minus two-thirds is
one-third we divide by a fraction it's
like multiplying by the reciprocal we
get 81 eighths
that's an exact answer and that's the
sum